just watching out for that curveball ba
0.2.86 has spread across the globe and
finally come to Canadian Shores Canada
detected the first case of the new
Omicron subvariant in BC on Tuesday with
children returning to classrooms and
with covid RSV and the flu circulating
big breath
experts are preparing for a possible
tripodemic with this infectious disease
specialist saying masks should make a
return particularly in the school
environment or where I work at a
university and some of the
post-secondary institutions I think
whether you have a mandate or you have a
strong recommendation for people who are
mass I think that's reasonable right now
the sub-variant doesn't appear to cause
more severe illness but it could be more
infectious doctors are urging caution
just saying it's personal preference and
that people who are at home can wear a
mask is not the answer because just
wearing a mask if you're in a high risk
setting is not good enough now the
science is clear masks help stop these
viruses from spreading and an infection
can be devastating for those who are
immunocompromised or elderly Evans and
Clay say we're not likely to see many
people wear a mask without a mandate but
whether or not anything will change is
not a medical decision I don't see
politicians wanting to embrace that in
any shape manner or form because
um there's vocal minor vocal groups on
each side experts say masks are part of
a multi-pronged approach
Health Canada is testing new vaccines
better suited to the strains currently
circulating and it's hard to tell yet if
new subvariants and other viruses will
cause another wave of cases and
overwhelm hospitals but Public Health
experts agree the severity of the
situation
could largely depend on how many people
take action Nathaniel Dove Global News